Daredevil a blind hero draped in red and
fighting for the Justice in the shadows
may seem like another action-packed
story but beneath the surface lies a
dangerous deception with religious
overtones the hero Embraces violence as
a means to the end this subtly redefines
morality can we truly call a man that
Dawn the devil's identity as a champion
of Justice let's take a look at the
messages behind Daredevil and what this
all means
all right guys today we're talking about
Daredevil and it's going to be
ridiculously
obvious okay are you ready for this what
is obvious there there there isn't much
uh to uh explore here that is going to
be shocking their devil I'm sorry what's
what's wrong with
that we have this superhero character
and I think it's very interesting that
uh you know today's world we we don't
have a problem with with putting the
devil into entertainment and in fact
they're making it just straight cool mhm
that's what they want you to think and
and you know the devil doesn't look like
this right nope does he have a red
Pitchfork and you know no he doesn't
look like that at all and so I think
what this can kind of start to begin to
put into your mind is a a wrong picture
of even who the devil is but
nonetheless what is the name of this
series that they're putting out here
born again no is that Christian or not
no well it is a Christian terminology to
be born again it is but not in relation
to the devil the devil is not the one
yeah that's what I meant sorry that's
what I meant you know what's funny to me
is everything that God does the devil
just wants to repeat M
why I mean if you can be the the best
copycat in the world then that would
cause a bunch of confusion wouldn't you
just want to go do something totally
different though like can't deceive
people that way yeah right like it's so
funny how how many things are evil but
then they like have some kind of tie
back to God yeah all right so we're
going to jump a little bit into this
what does it say at the top of the
poster there denique let the devil out
is that a good thing or bad thing I
don't think you want him out of anything
I I don't think you want him in in order
to let him out yeah that's that's not a
good point yeah you know like the devil
of Hell's Kitchen do you know what
Hell's Kitchen is Gordon Ramsey yeah
Gordon Ramsey Show a restaurant called
that as well right right but you know
what I mean they're they're kind of
having to play on words here obviously
the devil is associated with hell in the
Bible and so you know the fact that he's
cooking up some stuff it doesn't take a
rocket scientist to look at how evil
this character is and I think there's a
lot of kids who see these things as
innocent characters or I shouldn't say
innocent characters like benign
characters right there's not too much of
a problem because we know it's fake kind
of an idea yeah and he's supposed to be
a hero so people are looking up to this
character although he does you know some
things in the name of justice that you
know one could argue or taken too far
remind reminds me of suicide squat it's
the same setup I mean an actual fact uh
Batman is is associated with the demon
if you look into the history of it so
right he could very well be the Marvel
Batman for all we know doesn't really
have superpowers is based on you know
he's he's blind this character is blind
so he kind of like based on hearing
blind is a bat exactly he's a lawyer
he's a lawyer he's a lawyer so in fact
I'm going to play a little clip of the
trailer that they just released um a
little while ago and and I think the new
series is coming out so check this
out this city can't go un
[Music]
checked okay the devil's work is never
done is that interesting that is really
really interesting mhm the devil's work
is entertainment that's what they're
saying right now as well yeah yeah he's
working hard it's a lot of
interesting things about this you know
when you think of the justice system
Lady Justice she's also blind you know
you can take that multiple directions
but obviously with this kind of a series
his character being a
lawyer what is that communicating to
people that the justic ism is either
corrupt or it's not doing doing its job
so somebody else has to be the justice
system you know there's a lot the devil
has its hand lot of implications Justice
yeah yeah you know he's obviously in a
courtroom right here and so we've got a
lot of parallels going on with with
actually some deep spiritual ideas
obviously there is a war between Christ
and Satan and there is a judgment that
is going to happen right we have a
lawyer who's the who's our lawyer Jesus
Jesus how do we know that's our lawyer
he's our Advocate I think it's in
Hebrews so you're right the Bible does
speak about Jesus has been our lawyer
Keith can you read this sure 1 John 2:1
my little children I am writing these
things to you so that you may not sin
but if anyone does sin we have an
advocate with the father Jesus Christ
the righteous Jesus is our lawyer he's
our Advocate he's the one that's
standing in between us and God pleading
our case
the Bible talks about the reason why
Jesus had to come down to Earth because
a lot of people were getting a wrong
picture of God they were getting this
Blended thing that they thought good was
evil and evil was good and it's getting
all mixed up and Jesus had to come down
here listen to what the Bible says Den
can you read this 1 John 3:8 whoever
makes a practice of sinning is of the
devil for the devil has been sinning
from the beginning the reason the Son of
God appeared was to destroy the works of
the devil so isn't that interesting that
the Bible tells you Jesus's main
function that he's coming down is to
reset everybody in their correct
understanding of who God is that God is
loving and to destroy the works of the
devil and here we've got a TV series
that's like the devil's work is never
done it's interesting that Jesus says he
came to fulfill the law and this is
saying that he came you know to destroy
the Devil so yeah it's basically like
the devil loves to break the laws it's
totally opposite to what Jesus came to
to do yeah and what is what is the
definition of sin it is the lawlessness
sin is the transgression of the law so
that goes along with what you're saying
Plain on people sympathies too though
Sympathy for the Devil because his
character is supposed to be providing
the justice that you're not seeing
happen so when the bad guy gets
off yeah you know it's an interesting
thing that they're proposing by by by
putting this idea of this devil out
there but he's doing good things I think
that's a subtle way for to rewrite who
the devil really is in people's minds
you guys mentioned that Matt Murdoch
that's who plays this character um the
Daredevil and he is a lawyer and uh if
you look at this it says that uh he
works as a lawyer in Hell's Kitchen we
pointed that a little earlier but look
at what it says right here he was
blinded in a childhood accident attorney
at law Matt Murdoch protects Hell's
Kitchen as the Mas
vigilante um so this this whole born
again um series is really this this is a
comic book that it was based off of in
this comic book was written a while ago
and um what do you see on the picture
here it looks like they're inside a
church they're in a church mhm did you
notice the church music in the back of
the um the trailer that we watched no I
didn't a church
organ oh this is this is some
interesting stained glass though yeah
because you have the nun with a Halo and
the symbol of the Holy Spirit the dove
coming down in placement of a Jesus
right but you also have Santa Claus
there in the background between
Daredevil and the woman you have Captain
America on the right in the stain glass
so what is why does he belong there you
have this other guy in the bottom left
it looks like a a bad guy you have
another guy above him with a machine gun
like why do they belong in stained glass
and then a bunch of people burning in
Hell people burning in Hell on the
bottom yeah and he is going and grabbing
a woman MH yeah you know it's like
there's some orig there's some seriously
like occultic things in this picture can
you explain why that matters a woman
what is a symbol of in the Bible the
yeah the woman the woman is a symbol of
the church that's why um in Ephesians um
it talks about you know husbands love
your wives even as Jesus has loved the
the church right and so those two things
kind of get linked together but you know
you got a guy down here with a AK-47 or
something like that I mean there the
things that you see in stained glass are
usually things from the Bible or from
God this is very Twisted what do you
guys see about some of these this is the
this is the comic series that really
this character is based off of oh the
titles are all of lots of religious
biblical somehow yeah oh but it's just
make believe
stories still you're imprinting those
God and countries saved apocalypse
here's what I think that the devil
understands about us we we are
supposedly in this Christian Nation
right we we we've all pretty much heard
of God and and you know it's like as
time gets going more H people are not
unaware of this sort of struggle between
God and Satan I think he's replacing
that desire to look into these things
he's giving you an alternative right
here he's giving you the counterfeit
very easily you want to learn about the
Armageddon the end of the war oh it's
not an end of the war between Christ and
Satan it's an end of the war between
these two characters or whatever right
who's going to save you there's no
picture in here of Jesus saving you it's
the guy that's in the devil do you do
you know what this word is Pariah
anybody want to take a stab at what that
is sacrifice dictionary
definition okay we're going to get to
that in just a second
bre I'm sorry do we know each other it
seems like maybe we've met before I
don't know this is uh it's awkward
though just as much for me as it is for
you I really wish I had a conversation
starter oh hey oh what's on my shirt and
this is the story of the Three Angels
message from Revelation 14 wow that
totally worked you know if you have
trouble starting conversations like me
maybe you should try lightwear
[Music]
look at the imagery that's on the cover
there you can just see how many times
they put a cross in there he's sitting
on the cross and it's like a devil's
face and like I mean there's some just
this says into the fire right here this
says the root of evil Heart of Darkness
I mean all of these things are really
messed up right these are kind of some
imageries that are inside of these these
uh comic books and as you can tell
there's just just did nothing but
Blasphemous types of things making
mockery of the Christian cross and stuff
here's what PR says Keith what does that
say says it's an outcast
interesting interesting that it's an
outcast and he is a D devil devil was
cast out of Heaven as an outcast someone
who was rejected or cast out as from
home or from society or in some way
excluded looked down upon or ignored mhm
that's exactly how he wants you to feel
about him that's right Sympathy for the
Devil poor me I got kicked out I lost my
home and I'm here to protect you that's
what he's trying to tell these
generations and and you know kids aren't
thinking of this like that they're not
looking at this with like well what does
my Bible say well what does this guy say
right here they're just looking at these
colorful pages and all the like you know
details that's there and and and and
then getting distracted by the story
yeah and also um these titles for these
comic books are very intentional I
didn't know what I've never heard this
word before I didn't know what it was
right so clearly somebody out there
who's writing this comic book is like I
have this concept in mind I'm going to
find some kind of word uh that that
explains that I put I put that on there
even though nobody knows what it means
somebody's going to understand this
concept and it's going to plant a seat
in their heart that's a great point
because a lot of times we fi a lot of
questions about these kind of of
projects where people are just like oh
you're looking too deeply into it really
I mean is that too deeply looking into
it when it's like so layered in there
with so many different like imageries
and and and they're just highlighting
what the devil is feeling and they're
putting it on the cover in in the
documentary that we made the replacement
Gods there was a clip in there of I
remember who it was but he was a really
well-known comic book author you might
know who I'm talking about yeah the guy
who did um the My Chemical Romance
something Gerald I don't know if it's
was referring to the same person but he
was the one who openly said that he's he
basically channels Grant Morrison yeah
Grant Morrison probably he channels
demons and that's like he has like we
call it automated writing or something
like that like he's like I'm not writing
myself something comes into me and I
write down the story and then also he um
when his character was experiencing
something like sickness or sweating or
almost died he experienced the same
thing yep he was writing the story that
he himself was experiencing shortly
after gr opened himself up to the occult
performing his first ritual by invoking
his spirit in the form of a l I tried
this ritual I did the whole thing I got
the candles I did the magic W I did the
circle I did the banishing and all that
stuff and I stopped and I went to bed
and then this thing happened when I was
lying down and right in front of me
there was a kind of gravitational point
in the air in the room which was drawing
all the perspectives towards it as if
there was a hole there or a crack
and there was the sense of black oil
filling up the folds between the brain I
just freaked out and called on the God
my mom and dad you know Jesus get me out
of this one and the whole experience
ended after a little bit and then there
was this vision of a lion's face which
started to announce stuff so it seemed
pretty convincingly cing to me that i'
actually somehow activated whatever it
was he was talking about this became
part of Grant's everyday life I came
past his room to see if he wanted a
drink and it took a while for the door
to open and when it did it creaked open
slowly and I could see Grant who
appeared to be wearing nothing but a
gray
blanket tugged over his
head I said do you want to come out for
a drink and no I'm writing I'm having
breakthroughs and then the door closed
again and the thing is I didn't see him
touch it it
just closed all on its
own in Grant's book super Gods he says I
came out in boils a traditional sign of
demon contact I hallucinated something I
recognized immediately as Christ I
understood that this power I was facing
was some kind of Gnostic Christ a Christ
of the Apocrypha and almost Pagan figure
that I'd found at the bottom at the last
gasp
you know I'd become the character I was
wearing the clothes I was going to the
places I was doing the things I was
doing the rituals I was hanging out with
the gods and then putting it back in the
comic and then being affected by what
was in the comic so yeah in terms of
reality that one was the actual deal you
know that one was bringing me to the the
verge of death when Grant was working on
the Invisibles he got sick right around
the time that character got sick just
after King M had been convinced by the
bad guys that he'd been given a
necrotizing fasciitis bacteria that was
eaten through his face I suddenly get
this huge boil in my face and within 3
days it's enormous distorted my entire
feature I was I was sweating constantly
I was getting into fevers and having
these like shakes and rers and then
freezing I just couldn't get up anymore
and I lay in front of the the fireplace
in my house I mean he thought he was
going to die I mean he broken he broken
down in tears and he was like he was
delirious man delirious and suddenly
this giant column of light comes through
the door and be in mind I'm hallucinate
but this is one of the most amazing
hallucinations I've ever had and it's
Jesus the first thing he said which is
the thing I put in the com just this
voice suddenly announced itself I am not
the god of your fathers I am the hidden
stone that breaks all Hearts so then he
sent mil you're about to die now but you
don't have to die and I said I really
don't want to die what do I have to do
and he said well if you want to stay
here you have to work for us you know
you have to spread the away yeah Gerald
Way um was sitting there with Grant
Morrison and they were at a convention
with this thing like the stand that
looked like a devil and he was basically
saying look we're rewriting the Bible
like people that follow us their
disciples there's a reason why we call
them disciples and he thought this was
the greatest thing in the world to
basically hand the generation that's
watching and paying attention to all
these things the morality this is where
they're getting the morality not from
the Bible we're we're giving them this
mhm so interesting all right I want to
show you a couple clips from the trailer
I was raised to believe in Grace I was
also
raised to believe in retribution what
did he
say he said something about Grace in the
beginning Grace was I was raised to
believe in grace yeah I was also raised
to believe in retribution what is the
difference between those two well GRA
with Grace you're going to receive Mercy
with retribution you're going to receive
Justice or Vengeance mhm so here's what
retribution means from the dictionary go
ahead and read that Felipe punishment
inflicted on someone as Vengeance for a
wrong or criminal
act revenge is a good way to say that M
yeah seek revenge is that what we're
supposed to do nope no vengeance is mine
says the Lord ah good let's let's read
that Romans 12:19 Keith can you read
this beloved never avenge yourselves but
leave it to the wrath of God for it is
written venges is mine I will repay says
the Lord yeah we are actually not called
to go out like Vigilantes and take the
law into our own hands let God do that
especially at this day and age and and
and why do you think that that today we
some people read the Bible and they go
well they they did that in the Old
Testament they they you know picked up a
spear and ran the guy through because he
was taking a girl into his tent why
don't we see that today how would you
answer that I mean the way the way I
understand it is you're living in
different times during that time uh
Israel was living in a
theocracy um during a lot of those those
Acts or um they had a a living prophetic
um person who was telling them you need
to go do this or do that so you know
that if you have somebody like Moses and
he's the go between between you and God
and or a judge of Israel it's they're
kind of getting their directions
explicitly directly from God himself
it's interesting because you know it's
it's one person clearly identified or
probably even agreed upon by the people
it's not just anybody and everybody kind
of coming up and saying I hear from God
you know typically we hear that now and
we tend to think you're crazy MH you
know and we know that God's not going to
go against his word so if somebody
arises up and says you know I'm hearing
from God I should kill these people no
you're not you know that's against God's
word you know he's not going to tell you
to kill so people will bring that up you
know it's like well these people back
then killed but they're also living in a
you know it's like a you're in a war or
this is a rebellion or this is a um
direct attack on you know God or
something so yeah we are living in a
different day and age that um we're not
all receiving direct yeah Communications
about those things and you also got to
think that before during those times
there was no Jesus and there was no
Jesus's sacrifice yet because
now the uh Jesus died for everybody's
sin right for everybody that has sinned
against you or against anyone Jesus died
for that for them and for you so the
same the same
same uh reward that you should receive
for your sin is do also for the other
person Jesus has died for their sins
just like you so you shouldn't be uh
putting Vengeance on anyone because
Jesus also died for that person yeah I
kind of understand it as a parent you do
kind of you know you tailor sometimes
your
your parenting at to the children in the
way that they respond best and you're
going to parent them slightly different
and that doesn't mean like favor over
one or the other it just requires a
different like like my son if you know
you you um were to scold him or whatever
I mean he would just you know
immediately go okay I'm sorry sorry
sorry but my daughter might do something
totally different so the way that you
approach that is a little different and
I think that that if we look at the
history and the pattern of how God
worked with man he had to work with man
back then in that state but we have an
incredible amount of information at our
fingertips we don't need that kind of
thing at this point and and so I think
you see a big difference Leviticus
1918 says you shall not take Vengeance
or bear a grudge against the sons of
your own people but you shall love your
neighbor as yourself I am the Lord so
here's in the Old Testament an example
right here where even Jesus is telling
him and don't don't don't take Vengeance
I think it's fascinating too if you look
at a lot of those stories where they
went to war or what have
you God clearly would have worked on
their behalf if they would have relied
or trusted in him more he didn't need
them to necessarily go to war and he'd
have done it with the with the
Grasshoppers do he
do something and so there's there's a
little bit of that at play as well where
they're not complet trusting in Him or
or or they just choose to take matters
into their own hands you know in a way
that you know how cool would that have
history have been if they would have
been totally driven out all of those
people with not even touching them been
amazing test and when you see a little
bit of that in the plagues of
Egypt true people didn't people didn't
do anything yeah the story of Gideon as
well they didn't really go down and
fight they killed each other it's true
and that's reflected in the end of time
too because there's you know the seven
last plagues it's not God's people
fighting or doing anything to the rest
of the world those plagues are coming as
judgments of God God is just taking care
of it yeah yeah very true all right here
the clip kind of continues on and um
this is Daredevil having a conversation
with the villain of the story and uh
listen what he
says why did you stop being a vigilante
so he stopped wanting to be a vigilante
for a little while this this was brought
up a little bit earlier a vigilante this
is what it means a
self-appointed group who undertake law
enforcement without legal
Authority people that take matters into
their own hands and don't care about the
law and they're going to do whatever
they feel called to do and and and
eradicate people or you know kill them
off or whatever because that's outside
the law that's kind of what the devil's
doing mhm interesting that he's doing
that as a lawyer isn't it
yeah yeah he should be upholding the law
yet he's a Vigilant see he's he's this
two-sided like speaks out of both ends
of his mouth at this point so are you
offended At
All by this picture I mean he's whipped
on his back oh I
see yeah it's clearly a portrayal of of
Christ right so he's in the shape of a
cross he's whipped on his back he's
naked yeah so at least from the top up
he is not
clothed where do you understand like
what what's the scene is are we going to
see that or this just one of the posters
that they put out okay a poster so it's
not even you didn't pause this yeah it
was promoting um one of the series that
came out I think in in
October 2 Corinthians 4:4 says in their
case the God of this world has blinded
the minds of the unbelievers to keep
them from seeing the light of the Gospel
of the glory of Christ who is the image
of God the reason why I asked is is this
offensive is because that very symbol of
Jesus being on the cross is the very
symbol of God's love stretched out over
Humanity he hung on a tree that was like
the worst painful death that anyone
could ever experience he was willing to
go and sacrifice himself so that you and
I could have a chance to live forever
that's the kind of God that we serve and
to put the devil in that position to me
is offensive he has not sacrificed
anything for you in fact he sacrificed
our families he's he's broken us up he's
he's Twisted Humanity to constantly Ward
each other I mean we we we were supposed
to be one people on this whole planet
and just reflecting the love for each
other and look at the division that it's
caused really nobody can take that
symbolism
on
appropriately you know no no human being
no character outside of Christ not even
the angels could could you can't you
can't because nobody can pay that
price so it's sad to me that when I see
things like this that you know make such
a a strong dance with their imagery or
you know just sort of poking fun at or
you know having imagery of upside down
crosses and somebody being crucified or
tortured or something like that and it
doesn't bring your mind to Jesus I think
that just Waters down the image in your
mind and begins to make it fuzzy mhm
yeah so what do you call it the most
powerful Church in America I will give
you an example and show you how powerful
the movie theater is in this country
now what time does your church meet on
the weekend Sunday morning let's say I
go to your church and preach the morning
seron halfway through
discernment I curse the name of Jesus or
as some would say I use the lord's name
in
vain will that not wake up your
congregation so then I preach a little
more and I curse his name again how
would they react to
that then I preached a little more and I
curse his name
again but did people not be
upset then I bring up a young couple on
the
platform and they start to kiss and take
their clothes off right there in church
on Sunday morning how long do you think
your congregation will allow this to go
on would they not say this is most awful
thing to curse the name of Jesus in
church and to have them take off their
clothes here in front of everyone would
they not be appall would they not yell
out stop it you cannot do this in this
place but yet I say 12 hours earlier on
Saturday night in a movie
theater when this exact same thing
occurs it is entertainment
my friend something is wrong we must
make up our mind it is either
entertainment Saturday night in the
theater and entertainment Sunday morning
in church or it is most
sinful Sunday morning in church and most
sinful Saturday night in the
theater this is why I say the movie
theater is the most powerful Church in
America
is the only place where Christians
go to hear the name of Jesus Christ used
as a swear
word and to watch
nakedness and yet pay their
money to be
entertained never thought of it like
that before I say this trembling David
most people who go to church in the
America no not
Jesus the Bible says in the last days
men will become lovers of pleasure more
than lovers of
God is this not the case in America
now ask
yourself would I go to the movie theater
to hear my name cursed then why go to
the theater to hear his name
cursed David
would you go to the theater to see your
daughter naked on the
screen so I go see someone else's
screen it's this great
sinfulness in the eyes of
God I don't know what to
say what can we do
must try and turn this all around use
the movie theater for
Jesus we need dramatic programming on
television for the Lord use radio to
tell others the gospel Satan does not
want any of this to happen and will work
to stop anyone who tries to change it so
beware I
understand the media has the power in
this country David the airwaves the
movies the music it is how the enemy is
working just look around you and observe
what really moves the people and
influences their lives is it not
entertainment and the
media they control the
people they have the power of the
[Music]
air that video Felipe that you made that
was a um
a little short video that the guy was
talking about um you know going
and taking your clothes off in the
middle of church or using the the lord's
name in vain in in in church how
offensive and inappropriate that would
be that video is so powerful to
illustrate a certain point how many
people are going to go to church
listening to the word of God tell you to
love your enemies tell you to do kind
things to other people to turn the other
cheek all the things that Christianity
is really trying to promote for us only
to go Saturday night and go and watch
this MH how many people are going to sit
in church and only hours later listen to
God's name just literally be blasted by
something like this or at home yeah yeah
and I think you know to be fair to
people there's probably a point in your
life where you're you're just not
thinking about it mhm know that's true I
was there you rarely see what you just
saw right there with a Bible text up
next it to it and you're right this is a
lesson where we have to start to hold
the Bible up to the world that's around
us we have to be going hey what does
this thing say and what is that thing
telling me it's it's either you're not
thinking about it or you believe that
God really doesn't care that much about
your own personal
choices and you know that that I think
is also problematic
because if he doesn't care about your
personal choices then you know does it
does he care if you
lie care if you steal does he care I
mean he doesn't care about those
things and you know and then eventually
where that leads is well I can do those
things but God will forgive me well
that's presumption or I can do those
things and God doesn't really care that
much or God will not judge me for those
things I think that's that's really
where that that kind of thought process
goes God will not judge me I won't lose
Heaven because of that because Jesus
died for my sin but but if you flip that
on its head it's like well Jesus died be
because of sin like the fact that it
even
exists he never wanted it to so why do
we want to create more of it and
also when you go and do something
thinking oh but God's going to forgive
me after anyway that's not real genuine
asking for forgiveness that's not
genuine repentance and I don't believe
that God can forgive that unless there
is real repentance if you have that
mindset and afterward you're like God I
really messed up should never have
thought this way I should never have had
this presumptuous you know mindset about
Sin please forgive me that God forgives
that but if you go in and like H you
know watch this movie hey got forgive me
okay next one like that God wants to see
a change of
heart I loved in that video that he
brought up the point of something that
you see commonly in Hollywood movies you
know like a like a sex scene or
something like that and he brought that
up in church and when he said that in
that video did you not feel
uncomfortable like this is
uncomfortable you should feel
uncomfortable about that when you see
somebody blasphemed God you should feel
uncomfortable about that in the in the
the theater or at home or whatever if if
somebody is doing something that is
completely against what God wants you
for you to do I I I would be scared if
your sensitivity goes away to that I I
was sitting in the theater once and this
is no I don't not mean this as a tap on
my shoulder like hey I'm good or
anything like that um but I was sitting
in the theater once and we were watching
um I was with a friend we were
watching um I don't know it's this movie
that's based on a Christian book like a
novel and so we were like oh we'll go
watch a Christian movie it wasn't the
shack was it no no no it was some other
one um some some movie by France the
book was by Francine Rivers um anyway so
we were went to see it it was beautiful
it was really well Illustrated there
were some scenes in there I was like but
then there was a sex scene in there and
my friend and I were looking to like in
a Christian movie yeah you're like okay
this is really awkward and but you know
you're you become so numbered to it that
everybody sits there and thinks it's
normal to watch people have sex in front
of you everybody we all here together
looking at two people having sex and I'm
sure they weren't showing like nudity
they weren't showing like the body parts
but you understood absolutely what was
going on and there were all the sounds
and everything and I was like this is
really uncomfortable yeah and some
people might think like oh no I always
skipped those parts but those are the
parts that you notice you know a while
back Keith made a presentation about
versus that are included in movies
popular movies and some people or most
people might might not even notice those
verses are in there not only that the
verses are out of context yeah right so
they're implanted in your mind as you
know the the verses are wrong and it
gives you the wrong message but it's
biblical right yeah and we're not saying
any any of this to like slam these
people or saying like oh we're better
than other people it's it's we're just
trying to bring up the concept of that
you know the Holy Spirit wants to wake
everybody up and like he said we were
their ones we're not better it's not us
that's doing it it's the Holy Spirit
praise God that wants to wake people up
and and I'm I'm just hopeful that you
know somebody will watch this and
realize you know maybe maybe it's true
maybe this kind of stuff is is is not
honoring God and and maybe we we need to
have a closer walk with the Lord focus
more on him you're bringing up a really
good point um that I certainly have
engaged in a lot of these these types of
movies all yeah and and have seen my
fair share of evil but I stand firm on
that God is can heal you he can heal
your mind and it's not that those images
are completely like I don't even see
them anymore it's like you know like
music right every once in a while you
see something and you'll be like oh yeah
I remember remember that whole scene um
but my sensitivity has come back and
that's what we hope by showing these
kind of things that our audience you
guys out there will see these um sort of
short explanations of the Bible says
this and tells you not to have Vengeance
so why would you watch something that
inspires you for vengeance you know that
kind of stuff and and that you can make
better decisions down the road because
you're learning from our mistakes and
that's why we choose to bring these
things up so amen purify the Mind
Philippians 4:8 if you like this video
like subscribe and hit the notification
Bell so you know when we launch new
videos and drop a comments below and
we'll try to get back to you if we can
what say that again no no I don't know
what to say
[Music]